[Music]
in worst boss ever news that's Bart the
worst boss ever do cuz he punishes me
every night oh damn
thank you support that support it was
like somewhere in between of like
excitement and like that's cool
submitted by there is no Wi-Fi oh my god
I would die sorry a billionaire dubbed
America's worst boss this about you a
billionaire yeah just lost an 11 million
dollar harassment lawsuit well a
billionaire that doesn't matter
yeah that's ten bucks that's 11 bucks
for him I would love to be sexually
harassed by a billionaire how are ya oh
I would just take a little bit of your
money 1111 million I'll get that all day
for though it was sexual harassment what
was done yeah I need to hear I didn't
hear all the fact if he kissed me on the
ear and licked my ear hole maybe I'll
take that I'm down with that
oh for sure down with it it's pretty
crazy though because I know if somebody
who worked for a very very popular
company and she got sexually harassed by
an executive who got brought it up and
for her she was gonna quit that job
anyways or go somewhere else so she what
she did was they settled on a certain
amount when his she asked for a higher
position above the person that's
actually asked them and then she got
placed in a higher position that
personified and then she got a fat chunk
of money and she stayed in the company
she stayed yeah she's like tough as
nails she'll give a [ __ ] she's like well
I'm gonna make this person pain I'm
gonna get my money so she just took her
fat chunk of money she got a higher
position above that person that person
uh [ __ ] I'm super down with getting
sexually harassed for 11 million I could
be in the corner smoking a vape pen
throwing [ __ ] doughnut holes and then
a guy my boss just come to stick his
dick in my mouth the doughnut hole its
mouth is open it's coming it's coming
yeah
[Laughter]
you jaw pulling out the rings and
everything is because really in focus
yeah you could be really especially like
you know blow the rings and then tap it
on the top so it turns into a heart on
the first mistake
11 million did I'd be done that's just
blackmail people with that dude his name
is elke David Holladay lki he's alkaline
yeah so he is a billionaire air and he's
holding air he's not even a billionaire
yeah Wow he is that we inherited the
billion oh he's an heir he already got
it yeah it says with holdings include
manufacturing bodily bottling plants
property and shipping we're also like
it's like coca-cola bottling plants and
he also founded hologram USA which is
known for creating Holograms dead
celebrity was like Tupac like Michael
Jackson oh that's really good that's the
only time I ever wish I went to
Coachella and the death Punk year just
one year that death why not yeah so this
is LG David yes he looks like he's
related to the Huxtables Oh like he look
like the dad was it called flexible Bill
Cosby Bill Cosby's dead yeah his dad so
he's 50 years old in case you're
wondering and he's essentially harass
somebody the victim she is rather being
sexually harassed by him than Harvey
Weinstein a Miss chastity and so she is
claiming that he walks around and he
actually admitted this like he walks
around the office there's dick you and
his underwear I know I mean I walked in
here was my pants no well they just have
to watch the previous five videos you
were naked the whole time uh that's
weird
yeah so then he does that and then he
also admitted to playing porn for staff
and he's just saying that
that's just stupid that's kind of weird
that is weird
that's just lack of common sense he
deserved and so she so chastity who's 42
years old she's 42 kind of 42 year old
looks like that my god she claims that
she was fired for refusing to engage in
sexual acts with him oh man but this
dude he's so out there that I'm gonna
just show you a video deposition and
also an Inside Edition interview Oh
actually crazy oh he turned albino he
turned up for our interview and a
$350,000 Rolls Royce convertible with a
Doberman therapy dog in the passenger
seat I never ever ever have ever touched
an employee of mine inappropriately the
only people I've ever touched
inappropriately I've married it's called
entertainment man it's called having fun
in the workplace it's cool it's called
listener called
they seen you so close to just know it's
not our gym right you know camera down
gay you'll get me on and then filing
lawsuits I'm just kidding TV yeah I
[ __ ] love it dude he's funny good
that made me feel oh [ __ ] oh this guy's
a nutcase
he's a nutcase but by the way did he
just admit to another crime because I'm
pretty sure it's also illegal to rape
your wife rape your wife yeah actually
have a hundred percent sure it's legal I
rape my wife every night because I know
it's appropriate yeah I would have just
been like hey someone should soon for
that to get an extra ten million that's
what my mind says like wait he can't
rape me the only person that says no
every night is my wife but it's okay
this is married
I just got shot in a pretension
appropriately that's what he said you
know what's crazy though is you know
billionaires are just rich people in
general or powerful people they live in
such a different world that their idea
of what is normal and what is okay is
completely different because they're
surrounded by yes men and all that [ __ ]
they're they're surrounded by crazy
people look at the Robert Kraft thing
like they're surrounded by gold diggers
that are that are just like wet ready
and willing to let them do what Robert
Kraft is the owner of the Patriots the
day they were playing against the
Cardinals I believe in the playoffs give
it to that Bravo
he went to the big you went to the
brothel in Florida and I'm like you're
that ring on it like why don't you just
if you have that much more dirt to your
room just get a process there realm of
reality is completely off not just not
to justify any of their actions but then
they also live very unapologetically
because rules don't apply the million
yeah I don't care but it's also because
he's not somebody who became rich too
from coming up he's an heir so he was
born in Tedesco so he's 10 times worse
he doesn't even know from the moment he
was born he just had billions of dollars
a what do they call that disease when
you're to influenza or influenza yeah
that's [ __ ] absolute Enza because
he's walking around he talks as if he's
God like he's untouchable yeah so he
doesn't understand right from wrong and
all that stuff
it was hilarious no it was a good it was
a good punch line he got me I definitely
wouldn't want a boss like he seems kind
of obnoxious but what I don't understand
is like that 11 million is a drop in the
hat fall right nobody's on like fighting
for it yeah there's a word but I forgot
but yeah so he plans on doing that like
he's like she's not gonna get a cent
well that's kind of good though because
people like that need a check from time
to time they need a reality check that
you can't be acting this way and the
only way to check them is in the wall
extremes like oh [ __ ] ok ok ok let me
back it up what about all the people
that plan this kind of [ __ ] to make trap
them they trap a rap yeah yeah yeah they
trap them to do things like that so they
can but like I feel like if you're
getting trapped you're already you're
riding that line between that's true if
you're a if you're a sleaze ball if
you're a sleaze ball you're gonna get
caught
people have a team and a lawyer like
uncle like he's probably texting his
lawyer all the time you know his best
was going on like all the coke machines
are in the back filling up the sodas and
he's just like sitting there just
watching bored just you know going at it
he's like you're all the employees look
at the porn I got on my projector grabs
a coke bottle session masturbating my
thanks for this money she was working at
the hologram thing I don't know so he
was like let's test my hologram penis
out I know oh my god does this work did
you look life-sized he legit sounds out
of touch though like he doesn't yeah at
all whatsoever it's so fascinating like
he he has got complex to the max well I
think if you're walking around the
office in your underwear and if you're a
billionaire I mean you're pretty up
there you're surrounded by yes man yeah
you're not surrounded by anyone that's
like you'll put on some [ __ ] pants we
tried that we'd all get slapped in the
face immediately he's like one of us
we'd be like what are you doing he's
trying to justify the porn to the
[ __ ] journal and he's having fun it's
called having fun and naughty war
mornings yeah I'm having fun guys not
sexual he goes no in California he goes
no it's not appeal is the word I just
remembered you know I masturbate in the
corner and I don't let the come touch
you we're okay but it's like Harvey
Weinstein masturbating in that plant he
did yeah there's a story you might want
to check this because I don't know the
facts but there's like a story about he
pinned a woman in the hallway of a
restaurant like none of this by the way
makes sense to me made it at physical
advancement obviously she said no he got
too horny got too horny started drinking
off and then like finished in a plan
like that was in the hallway restaurant
so I'm like my head's already going like
wow you've got some serious balls and to
where is every I hope it's a yeah first
I was like he just jerked off in the 20
seconds flat how many restaurants are
really dark maybe he was trying to give
the plant some nutrients but if I'm like
that girl I'm like running I'm running
out of the restaurant sprinting out of
the rest maybe he catches people off
guard of course it's just crazy like
people are just stupid
Oh slice that [ __ ] off yeah I wish I
wish you would masturbate
that's a weird statement yeah that is
just
but yes apparently that's a difference
so chest city's former colleague named
Elizabeth Taylor she knows a bit too she
also alleges sexual harassment and
wrongful termination and she filed a
lawsuit this is not fun
her allegations are expected to go to
trial and July so he's going down by the
way it's problem there's probably more
than - oh for sure yeah come out it's so
funny that he has an advisor that just
didn't tell them hey you shouldn't be
interviewed I got this he's like I'm
gonna take this I never did anything I
just masturbated in front it was unfair
it's unjust judgment he's like our Kelly
but the billionaire version exactly our
Kelly is a [ __ ] how old is 16 I want to
watch so many more interviews of this
guy I know I love watching people that
are just [ __ ] out of this world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]